leute ganz kurz noch bevor es losgeht
und zwar es richtig lies also das wäre
so eine kleine entschädigung vielleicht
von mir
wenn ihr mehr bei instagram ein bild
schickt vor dem teuersten produkt was
ihre busch gefunden haben dann schaue
ich was das teuerste von ai sachen ist
die ebene gesteckt hat man dann bestelle
ich das probiere das und was mit dem
stuhl passiert ist und in 2000 euro das
ist jetzt viel spaß
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video erneut ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut mir auch danke ich
muss sagen dieses video ist wirklich
sehr spontan und ich schiebe das jetzt
praktisch so dazwischen bei mir kommt ja
jeden tag um 19 uhr ein video schreibt
euch hinter die ohren ganz wichtig und
heute sollte eigentlich ein anderes
video kommen ich habe allerdings gerade
meine letzten videos durchforstet und
unter dem letzten botschafter und ist
wieder gleiche wie bei den anderen
bücher platz davor auf ist auch absolut
verständlich
es geht darum das übertrieben viele
leute schreiben ja alex was ist mit
diesem vielfältigen studien mit damals
bei uns bestellt aus für über 2.000 euro
blase war hast du uns verarscht kam denn
nicht an willst du mich verarschen du
kleiner sowie auch sehr so oft gelesen
nein hatte ich nicht vor und natürlich
ist da was vorgefallen ich bin nie
wirklich darauf eingegangen weil ich so
dachte hey dazu erst ein ganzes video zu
drehen um das wieder auf zu klären ist
auch unnötig also ich habe damals nicht
gemacht dann habe ich ganz lange keinen
riss content mehr gebracht oder bei
irgendwelchen plattform gestellt wie
wish you go war vorüber ist irgendwie
neue da habe ich jetzt auch bestellt die
leute ihr könnt ihr auch so coole videos
freuen ich bin sehr gespannt darauf was
da bei mir ankommt auf jeden fall kam da
diese kommentare nicht und jetzt habe
ich wieder angefangen mit diesem buch
videos ab und zu mal da was bestellen da
was bestellen da was bestellen
und ich lese dass jetzt halt andauernd
unter jedem video also für die die jetzt
gar keinen plan haben die rede ist von
diesem video und hier könnt ihr ja
gerade auf diesem stuhl sehen
es ging halt darum das teuerste produkt
auf ganz frisch zu bestellen und ich bin
halt irgendwann bei diesem stuhl gelangt
und habe ihn dann halt letztendlich auch
bestellt also ich habe ihn wirklich mal
bestellt und dazu würde ich euch ganz
gerne noch kurz was erzählen weil ich es
absolut nachvollziehen kann dass viele
sich so denken ja als wenn der wirklich
für 2000 euro diesen stuhl bestellt hat
ja das ist auch natürlich das ist eine
extrem hohe ausgaben für ein video 2000
euro einfach mal so weit allerdings kann
ich das ganz gut begründen und zwar habe
ich den im dezember 2018 bestellt und
habe
bemba 2018 im dezember 2018 auch da gab
es zum beispiel diese woche wohl wo ich
eine woche lang jeden tag dort was
bestellt habe und diese videos ich kann
zeigt offen und ehrlich sagen die waren
krank monetarisiert es war schon recht
nicht mehr normal so ich schäme mich
auch fast ein bisschen dafür euch das zu
zeigen
aber ich zeige euch mal kurz und
vielleicht könnt ihr das dann auch
verstehen alleine dieses video das
teuerste produkt auf ganz frisch
bestellt hat 250.000 news und damit habe
ich 1000 knapp 1500 dollar verdient und
dann muss ich auch sagen das ist gar
nicht mal so viel gewesen also ich hatte
davor hat videos die waren noch besser
monetarisiert und ich habe mir halt
gedacht wenn du dazu zwei videos drehst
jedes video 150 tausend klicks erreicht
dann kommst du da mit einem plus minus
null vielleicht sogar ein plus wert
drauf deswegen und das hört sich jetzt
vielleicht erstmal ein bisschen dumm an
aber das war so halt meinen denn bei
2000 euro einfach mal so eben raus zu
schmeißen ist natürlich viel geld wenn
es nicht irgendwie wieder reinkommen ich
habe da ja dann auch gleichzeitig
aufwand mit zwei videos zu produzieren
die zuschneiden und so weiter
und deswegen dachte hey komm du ziehst
du es wirklich mal durch soviel erst mal
dazu und jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt
ja gut warum ist hinter gittern nicht
bei der angekommen und du hast kein
video dazu gemacht lange story ist auch
schon ein bisschen was her genau ins
detail gehen kann ich leider auch nicht
mehr das was jetzt auch irgendwie fühlte
mir auch ein bisschen dumm dass jetzt so
zu erzählen wie ich erzähle aber es war
halt einfach so ich hab da auch mail
verkehr gehabt das war allerdings meine
alte mail da hatte ich noch keine eigene
geschäftliche mail die ich wie ich sie
jetzt habe praktisch und von dieser mail
wurde irgendwann mal so spam mails an
freunde von mir oder kontakte von mir
geschickt mit sehr erotischem inhalt und
dann musste ich diese mail vom netz
nehmen und ich hab sie gelöscht deswegen
habe ich diesen mailverkehr den ich
damals wegen dem scheiß stuhl hatte
nicht mehr das tut mir sehr leid aber
kann ich auch nichts dran ändern
entweder ihr glaubt mir das jetzt oder
halt nicht okay ich habe jetzt gerade
noch einmal versucht die mails zu finden
absolut nicht geschafft ich bin dass wir
sind aus dem konzept gekommen
deswegen versuche jetzt um reinzukommen
ich habe am 13 12
diesen stuhl bestellt genau für knapp
2000 euro wie gesagt habe jetzt auch
schon zum dritten mal gesagt ich kenne
mittlerweile mit der lieferzeit und
einem zu besucher gut aus normal dauert
es immer so
bei produkten die aus china kommen die
sind immer so mit vier fünf wochen
lieferzeit angegeben also kommt
spätestens bis in vier oder fünf wochen
an meistens sind die schon nach
zweieinhalb bis drei wochen da also so
habe ich die erfahrung gemacht auf jeden
fall habe ich diese studie am 13 12
bestellt und dann auch direkt das video
hochgeladen und das video ist glaube ich
in den ersten tagen auch relativ gut
angekommen viele leute von meinen
abonnenten haben das gesehen und auf
instagram also habe ich viele nach
hinbekommen wann kommt denn dieser
scheiß stuhl weil nach einem monat kamen
noch kein video zur auflösung und ich
hatte halt schon damit gerechnet dass
ich das dann in einem monat drehen kann
und euch diesem spiel zeigen kann man
kann in seinem eigenen profil dann den
versand verfolgen da ist ein balken da
steht dann versandt ich kann euch das ja
gerne hier einbinden wird bearbeitet
versand fast da und dann kommt es zu dem
und dem datum an so war das halt auch da
und irgendwann ging es halt gar nicht
mehr weiter und dann dachte ich oh ist
in dieser studie müsste jetzt mal kommen
der wald hat dann sind waren sechs
wochen schon rum keine ahnung der war
immer noch nicht da und ich habe den
damals weil es so viel war über
kreditkarte bestellt genau also über
meine kreditkarte und irgendwann habe
ich dann halt diese mail bekommen dass
der stuhl nicht geliefert werden kann
weil er im zoll fest hängt das blöde war
der war nicht im zoll in köln sondern in
frankfurt ich hatte das schon mal dass
ich ein handy das über 100 euro gekostet
hat hier in köln beim zoll april musste
das handy kann man aus china
da musste ich glaube ich so 15 euro
drauf bezahlen ich weiß gar nicht mehr
ganz genau war auf jeden fall echt nicht
viel und einige von euch haben auch
unter dieses video geschrieben er ja
alex da kommt noch eine dicke
nachzahlung an zollgebühren auf dich zu
und so war es dann letztendlich auch ich
habe irgendwie gehofft also ich hatte da
noch nicht so viel ahnung vom leben muss
ich ehrlich sagen ich habe eigentlich
gehofft dass das einfach so durchgeht
aber bei so hohen summen dann auf keinen
fall also ich glaube dass es sehr
unwahrscheinlich auf jeden fall viel
dieser stuhl in die kategorie möbel
möbel sind relativ hoch fahrzeug also
zumindest höher als zum beispiel elektro
ware oder so und dann wollten die von
mir noch mal irgendwas über 600 euro
haben halt als zeuge wird und da darf
ich also na super
ganz schön teuer schule verdammt eurer
stuhl also ich glaube nicht dass ich das
mit zwei videos dann auch nur an
entweder rein kriegen und dann ging es
weiter dann sachen die beim zoll liegen
muss man selber danach so also zumindest
diesem stuhl den soll ich dann selber
dort ab
um den stuhl abzuholen hätte ich mir
passt ja logischerweise nicht mein auto
auf keinen fall hätte ich mir ein
transporter mieten müssen in der
frankfurter müssen in diesem stuhl
irgendwie in diesem transporter kriegen
müssen sondern wieder zurück oder ich
hätte den transport und selber noch
bezahlen müssen dieser studie hat glaube
ich 75 kilo gewogen war relativ groß da
wäre dann irgendwie so ein fahrer
beauftragt worden und hätte mir den
stuhl vor beigebracht was auch nochmal
zwei wunder irgendwas gekostet ich weiß
es nicht mehr ganz genau nehmen es mir
nicht übel aber es war am ende auf jeden
fall ein sehr hoher betrag
und dann habe ich gedacht oder gesagt ey
was ist mit kreditkarte bezahlt du
kannst sie das zurückholen das ist mir
jetzt zu viel stress weil ich in der
zeit auf klausur geschrieben habe und
das habe ich dann irgendwie so
hinbekommen da war ich noch echt
glücklich drüber weil das wären 3.000
euro geworden am ende für den stuhl
also das hat sich halt so hingezogen und
da kam das noch drauf und das war drauf
und das noch drauf und niemand hat mich
selber keinen bock mehr und habe das
halt einfach storniert da musste ich
dann auch noch irgend eine gebühr
bezahlen das war mir dann aber egal
und das ist die story hinter dem stuhl
ja und ich hoffe auch das ist
verständlich ist für die meisten von
euch es tut mir wirklich leid am ende
war es natürlich meine schuld weil ich
so uninformiert an diese sache
rangegangen
dieser hohe bestellwert aus china großes
paket das sind so sachen die muss man
einmal erlebt haben und dann wird man
schlauer
deswegen ich hatte ja am anfang schon
gesagt wird wir gerne über installieren
da ist sich alex wie teure produkte von
risch und ich schaue dann wäre das
teuerste schickt und dann schaue ich
auch dass ich das produkt irgendwann mal
in meinen händen halten und auspacken
kann
da wird dann auch noch ein video zu
geben so vielleicht als kleine
entschädigung wenn ihr da bock drauf
habt würde mich freuen ansonsten was es
mit diesem erklärt video wie gesagt
nehmen sie bitte nicht übel morgen um 19
uhr gibt es dann wieder ein ganz
normales video wird ein cooles video mit
pascal von gestern da gab es ja gestern
schon ein blog zu cooler typ freu mich
drauf haut rein das war es bei mir